hey how's it going reject nation greg
and john here today we're going to talk
some more about spider-man
no way home this is going to be a
different kind of video i was i was
actually going to do it
by myself initially but john showed up
and i was like
i think we share similar thoughts on
this why don't you hop on here with me
buddy
i too i'm worried about spiderman no way
yes
it's like we cover so much about when it
comes to rumors and plot leaks and
are we looking forward to this movie
absolutely are we are there things about
that we're hearing things that we
believe
are going to be in the film that we are
very much excited about
undoubtedly and we spend so much time
lately sort of reveling in the
anticipation and the excitement for it
however there's this other side
where there are some things that we are
able to spit out once in a while like
we're honest if we think like this leak
sounds like bullcrap there are things
that we actually do
think are it seems like this is for sure
happening that is the flip side of
some concern that comes with that
package whether it be the history of
like earlier
parts of the marvel cinematic universe
whether it become the history of sony
specifically
or just storytelling making a movie in
general
and so we have like four things here
honest concerns honest
worries that we have that would be
interesting to kind of talk about on
camera and just right off the bat for
you guys
what do you think are things that might
have you a little bit concerned about
everything we've been hearing i
genuinely want to have like kind of a
conversation about this so i'll kick it
off the first thing would be this
ruining the legacy of bringing back some
characters right
i think for sure willem dafoe's gonna be
in there alfred molina has been not shy
at all about confirming it you know we
got jamie foxx in there and like you got
this flip side where jamie foxx can
perhaps have a little bit of redemption
as opposed to what he got with amazing
spider-man 2. but honest truth
spider-man 2 is my favorite one of any
of the spider-man movies and just one of
my all-time favorite movies
so i do have concerns that they might
kind of ruin
alfred molina i do have concerns that
they might
ruin green goblin as well what would
put me at ease is if i found out or
something you know came through
that sam raimi was involved in the
handling and the treatment of these
characters
if you're gonna bring them over here i
don't want to ruin the legacy
of what they did in the spider-man
movies i feel like alfred molina's
more likely because green goblin was a
villain and
died a villain even though he was sad in
the end but even in visions that harry
osborne was having
james franco would see him in the
villainous green goblin way so even in
his little
cameos and returns he'd return as like
sinister green goblin i just don't want
it to be undercut especially the journey
of alfred molina uh specifically
yeah i mean because so much of the end
of that movie comes in a character
turn and then to you know whisk him away
from that and to recontextualize that is
a risk
you know the mcu has established its
time travel rules as
if you get plucked off the timeline
that's just the next sequential event in
your world so i can imagine ways in
which maybe
time and universe multiverse tomfoolery
would not get in the way but at the same
time it does
make me concerned about you know if we
just start plucking villains out of
these movies because it would be so cool
to have them return and have that legacy
honored
it feels like there's a lot of potential
for slippage there and
and to not you know fully handle that
right in all the excitement of just
doing it in the first place and sam
raimi's involvement with doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness is sort of
long standing so
i would imagine that especially as as
many things seem to be tying in to that
movie
hopefully he was involved but yeah i
mean that is arguably the biggest
worry to me is is i would hate to leave
no way home
with a worse taste in my mouth for those
earlier movies too
you know because of it because yeah with
these villains coming back
it automatically makes it kind of a
sequel or a continuation
of those original movies i mean will it
make those original movies bad
no i guess the concern is they left off
a couple of these portrayals on such a
high
impactful note where their deaths were
so meaningful
and i don't want the deaths to feel
undercut knowing they're
coming back especially if they come back
in a way that is
unsatisfactory and with that in mind i
think the next thing is just
too many characters which i mean it's
ironic that this is spider-man 3 and
what sunk the original spider-man 3
way too many characters what sunk
amazing spider-man 2
way too many characters that's the
conflicting part like do i believe toby
maguire and andrew garfield are going to
be in this
i do believe it do i believe all these
other villains from past movies are
going to be in here i absolutely believe
it
am i excited at the prospect of that
yes absolutely very much so at the same
time i'm like but that generally doesn't
bode well
for a movie this movie still has to be
able to stand on its own two feet it's
not the same thing
as doing like a crossover movie of the
avengers films the things that came
before it
were films that were directly meant to
lead up to
the avengers crossover so you're
following a story timeline so when you
get to the time where you got like
infinity war you got all these
characters in here you can follow it
easily
and be emotionally invested in it where
here this is really depending
like rely if all these people are in
here just the villains
that is supposed to work off of you
having
seen and remember those mystery prior
spider-man movies and have the nostalgia
for it this has to be able to still work
on its own whether or not you have that
prior
emotional investment in those other
films you know there are people who just
might not have seen those movies you
know what i mean it's on the caliber of
like an 80s of shield or some of those
other marvel shows that were
clearly being secluded from being mcu
tied in
and they wanted to clearly be tied in
for the exact perspective yeah but i
think less people will go revisit those
spider-man and amazing spider-man movies
i'm talking about
mass population not just the people who
watch youtube videos and such and the
ones who are invested in this
conversation there's a bigger world
there's a bigger population out there
where they're like
well i don't need to watch those movies
they don't matter it's the mcu ones now
it's the tom holland ones now
yeah it's the same concern that i have
kind of with the what i'm hearing about
the flashpoint movie
is oh it's really relying on me being
invested in those other franchises
the ones that are not mcu and now you're
trying to bring it into the mcu
you'll have to do like reintroductions
for all these villains yeah and if you
have tobey mcguire and andrew garfield
they'll have to get reintroduced in some
way
as well at the end of the day the way to
have an impact is you have to have the
prior investment in them
and there's just so many characters
there's so many people you got to make
this flow
it's not the same thing as infinity war
end game where they're already
introduced you don't need to reintroduce
anyone
here everyone's going to require a
reintroduction yeah
absolutely and i mean you know not that
it will be the same scenario as infinity
war end game but if you look at those
movies one of the things you can gripe
about is that the abundance of
characters takes away from the ability
to expound on the emotional aspects of
the story and really
at least connect you to specific people
and those movies ride a lot off of your
association based on
the previous installments that have come
before i hope
that they're able to bring everybody in
in a way that allows them to honor them
as characters because it it seems really
easy
to lose that yes you know i mean peter
gets lost in his own movies already
without all these people you know
exactly and that's the next concern is
that this is not gonna feel
like a spider-man movie and it's gonna
feel like a spider-verse movie i imagine
but i'm still
itching for the strong tom holland
spider-man
movie there is a bit of a discourse i
think amongst spider-man fans i think
the one who shines like the biggest
light on that is the channel high top
films
i referenced him in a previous video
before i love his video essays and while
he seems to have like this real
like kind of distinct like he gets like
sad towards these latest spider-man
installments and i understand where he's
coming from i don't feel it to that
effect at the end of the day though it's
like you're hearing about this movie and
the least exciting thing
seems to be anything about tom holland
it's about all these other things
surrounding it and there seems to be
this heft and gravitas that
seems to be a little bit excluded from
here that even the andrew garfield ones
were
going for at least yeah whether or not
you like them they're
at least attempted to make it this is a
strong
peter parker tale they're trying to tell
which is what the toby films did and
then here i'm like well it doesn't seem
like they're
trying to make that the focus at all
ever since this spider-man came to the
mcu
it seems like so much of his
storytelling has relied on crossover
and not on standalone yeah and you're
obviously we're not going to get that
but i'm like
tom holland part's like the part i'm
least like they had such a good
cliffhanger far from home oh my god
people know the identity of spider-man
what a crazy plot you could set up for
part three that could be intense and now
it's like oh
fun doctor strange villains
yeah sinister six and everybody's here
so i am concerned about just kind of
like the
the long-standing like future legacy of
the portrayal of this
specific spider-man yeah that i'm
wondering if
years from now we might look back and go
you know there were things that they
just didn't quite do
yeah that they should have that they
ought to have done because it's easy to
get caught up in the moment in the
excitement
he's in the marvel cinematic universe
he's so fun and tom holland himself
is just so enthusiastic and likeable
that he encompasses our enthusiasm for
the very fact that these movies are
happening
the previous two i think by comparison
with the amazing spider-man and
spider-man
have a certain lack of you know real
emotional
loss and sacrifice for peter to grapple
with there's tony but that also echoes
across a lot of other places too where
you can experience that grief and so
yeah i feel like
it's also kind of up to this movie as
the third installment and as you know
i'm sure tom hall and spider-man will
continue well beyond this but you know a
trilogy
is a nice symmetrical thing and i think
it would be really nice if by this third
one they could
really make his peter parker and
spider-man together a substantial and
fully realized character
rather than yeah having the movies rely
so heavily on supporting characters and
other crazy stakes and circumstances
and i guess the last thing is i'm
already kind of concerned i feel like
we would be part of the contributing
factor to it as a lot of the audience
there
that's already suffered the wanda vision
effect which is there's been so
much hope and so much anticipation the
marketing has taken care of itself just
in the speculation
i'm concerned about a really loud public
disappointment
audience if it's not perfect yeah yeah
or as grandiose in the sense of how
it's being pitched right now here's the
thing i believe toby and andrew are
going to be in this movie
i do here's the other part of my
emotions if they end up not being in it
i can adjust like i can yeah i just had
this whole spiel about i want this to be
more of a tama
i want i still wanted to walk out being
like this tom holland's movie i think
there's a big
part of the the fan base that won't get
on board
oh yeah there's a certain contingency of
folks who if they don't show up
there will be right at least a very
vocal twitter backlash
she's on the taxi cabin
yeah just everyone's cracking after that
but those are
kind of just the honest concerns about
it because i know we're getting so
caught up in the hype of it all
and it's fun to do that but also the
more hype the more kind of nervous i get
at the back of my mind
i just wanted to do this video because
in case anyone's like you guys get
excited over everything i'll be like
well you know what i got one video i can
direct you to where i have some actual
concerns about this thing
i also get worried okay and here's
examples
that's why we're doing this because of
that one comment i read from that person
i don't remember
gotta prove it to him that he or she or
whatever you identify as
no matter who yeah no matter who we're
talking to we're always thinking of you
you whoever that is anyway guys do you
have any concerns you agree with
anything at all does it not matter like
is anything we say do you find any
validity
to it other than the fact that our
feelings are valid but do you find any
logical validity to it leave your
thoughts down below i
would be very curious to hear if there's
any of these things that you guys also
feel you can reflect as well we're still
excited i still can't wait for the
trailer i'm generally 99 very excited
about it
and then sometimes i just get caught on
my own thoughts and go
i do have some worries though one
percent crippling dread
yes yes absolutely big stakes man big
stakes
all right guys leave your thoughts down
below and yeah we'll catch you guys soon